and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn my name is Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 164 Ryan
it's beginning to look a lot like
Christmas yes it is that's because today
is Christmas Day if you're listening to
this the day Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas or happy holidays and Happy
Holidays on Happy New Year and happy old
year Ryan it's I figured today would be
the best time for us to sort of look
back we're just in the rearview for a
second we don't like to live in the
rearview mirror no you keep looking at
the rearview and driving forward then
you're gonna you're gonna crash I saw
what happened yesterday I was on La
Cienega Boulevard and there was a guy
who was looking up in the rearview cuz
someone was honking at him behind him he
was continuing to move forward yeah and
then BAM he really ran in as I ran right
I mean it was like a loud just there
bump their bumpers were scuffed and I
don't even want to scuff my bumper but
so living in the rear view is well I
mean this is what we're going in the
rear view mirror with this episode but
this isn't a good way we're not focusing
on you know mistakes we've made we're
not you know harboring resentment we're
not going over a list of people that we
hate in 2018 that's a different podcast
off with my list away no you know what
you're right but I think it's actually
important to look back in the rearview
learn lessons from the past and and sort
of reflect on on the year that we've had
you know for me it was it was the best
of times and the worst of times yeah
quite literally it was it was sort of
the this cyclical roller coaster of a
year for me health-wise it started off
in a valley in fact it was just over a
year ago you remember we were in
Washington DC and I had to miss the
event and was essentially hospitalized
and from there it's because I was going
through all those detox it was detoxing
from her
hurry and I won't go into all my laundry
list of health issues of a hat if you
want to listen to that we did a great
podcast with my doctor's episode 138
called health problems you can dive into
how I fixed a lot of the health problems
toward the end of last year in the
beginning of this year I was detoxing
from Mercury and also from c-diff and
going through that I started to feel
better and better and better after being
in that valley and in fact I would argue
that July and August this summer were
two of the best months I've ever had in
my life yeah we went on tour went on the
simply southern tour I remember having
so much energy after fixing my health
and then changing my diet was radically
simplified all I was eating was was meat
and greens and then and then come
September I reintroduced some carbs into
my diet and the bacteria and the fungus
and my gut particularly and my small
intestine went wild and just discovered
recently after doing about $1,000 worth
of tests that I have SIBO which is a
bacterial overgrowth and in the small
intestine and I am currently working
through you know eradicating it but man
it has been a difficult three months we
went to Brazil in September and ever
since coming back from there I've spent
a lot of time in the bathroom it's
become my my second holiday you thought
you thought maybe you pick something up
in Brazil but well I had a like a like a
parasite or something so so what is
going so what is happening with you
right now
it has nothing to do with going to
Brazil though correct we don't think so
no it was it was a heck of a coincidence
yeah but there were other coincidences
you know things that coincided with with
that and and so it was a bit of a roller
coaster year for me and we'll talk more
about that as because I don't have all
the solutions right now I'm on a 90-day
protocol to fix this SIBO to fix his gut
stuff but it is affecting me negatively
it is
is really difficult to deal with but the
good news is I have a plan to fix it I'm
working with my doctors and I have this
whole 90 day routine of well we'll get
into it later but all that to say the
year itself has been challenging for me
health-wise but it's also been
outstanding for me health-wise yeah it's
easy to look back and say I'll hear all
the bad things that happen it's like if
someone tweets you and they like I'll
Ryan I hate your haircut or whatever no
one would ever say such a thing but okay
in your fantasy world where someone
hates my haircuts at alternate universe
in this fantasy world you know you have
you have this one person and that sticks
with you but all the outstanding things
that happened all of a sudden dissipate
when something negative happens yeah so
I think it's important when we look back
to not just look back and say oh my god
this was awful but look back and say wow
I really learned a lot from having this
outstanding summer where I felt in peak
physical health and the good news is I
now have a baseline that I know I can
get back to and and to me that's
actually encouraging because despair
means there is no hope for the future
but if I look back I can just peek in
the rearview and say oh there's the hope
right there but when we're looking back
on on this year as well you and I had a
creative year a productive year
creatively yeah and I felt like we grew
a lot in terms of this podcast not just
the in size of the audience which is
great but how you and I really measure
growth is how much did we grow
individually and how much did we learn
by doing this podcast we started out I
think we started the year around it was
episode 103 or something like that so
we've done over 60 episodes for the
podcast but then another 70 plus for the
patreon podcast as well so for the folks
who are patreon subscribers we we do a
private podcast every week in fact this
week we're going to do ask the
minimalists anything you're
do an audio episode of asked the
minimalists anything so that you well
you you asked us a bunch a question that
we have voted your questions and we
answered all of those so you can check
that out over at the minimalists comm
slash support but I was hoping to do
today Ryan was look back in the rearview
of some of our favorite moments of 28 he
know many man when you sent me I don't
know if those an email or text but you
asked me like hey what next now what do
you what do you what are your favorite
episodes and there's a lot to choose
from in I know and I was so many to
choose I was overwhelmed I was looking
at this list I'm like that one's my
favorite and that one's my favorite and
that one's my favorite and this is
actually one of the problems when we
start simplifying our lives and people
get overwhelmed we you know we always
say that the average American household
has 300,000 items in it and people I
don't know where to start because that's
my favorite thing and that's my favorite
thing and that's my favorite thing can't
let go of that and for me if we did 60
episodes this year I had about 45
favorites right and so here are 45
episodes ladies and gentleman here yeah
here's 90 hours yeah this year's podcast
90 hours of minimalism yeah no one I can
do this oh yeah it's a remember radio
station to do that coming up next it's
three hours of hits from the 90s well
let's talk about some of your favorites
I know you picked two for this episode
and I picked two why don't we dive into
this first episode here Ryan we we I
think we both agreed unanimously this is
in our top three of all time yeah it was
episode 155 the episode was called love
with with Peter Rollins what what what
stood out to you about that episode I
just I really like I just like Peter in
general like having him on as a guest
and helping answer questions I just felt
way especially when it comes to love
because that is his field this is you
know kind of studying love and you know
amongst other things but but just having
him here in the studio answering
questions I felt like we had some really
really awesome conversation it's funny
though because I'm thinking about like
my favorite moments from the air or both
are both patreon episodes so we had the
we had
for for the ps4 the PostScript question
that we do for patreon and we had this
really awesome conversation about my
relationship with my dad and an in love
essentially and how that kind of works
between my father and I um it was like
it was a nice little therapy session for
me man it was great you know what I like
about the the patreon episodes I mean I
like doing the regular podcast
I love having this format and answering
the questions but with the the patreon
stuff that we do and we do you know
bonus episode every week so essentially
we do a second episode every week of the
podcast and they tend to be shorter
episodes or more attenuated but we're
able to let our hair down a little bit
and we're not constrained by the
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people who might hear an episode yeah
it's like oh these are the people who
actually get us these are our true
supporters what what Kevin Kelly would
have called true fans yeah yeah or who
was a kid Blanchard said raving fans and
and and to me the people who are
supporting us on patreon we really
appreciate you but also we show that
appreciation by by having these really
candid and Frank conversations that are
more difficult to have in public because
you have all that scrutiny of hundreds
of thousands of people and it's easy to
get to take something out of context but
with the patreon folks I feel like those
are the people who get us yeah well I
mean we don't have to adhere to a format
with the patreon episodes it's kind of
us just having a normal conversation
it's not like okay here's our voicemail
here's our social media question and
here's our recommendation it's it's a
little bit different each show there's
there's for me it's like yeah reform
yeah we get a let our hair down a little
bit cuz we can you know freestyle a
little bit more than then have that that
format that we're used to with every
single podcast if you beatbox all
freestyle tune in this week on pastry
our patreon supporters the other my
other favorite moment was when that dude
when Austin came on stage in Nashville
yeah like that was also a patreon
episode like so
I think like when I when I think about
the fields because you know how I love
the fields you love all the field I love
all the fields man and yeah those two
moments were were really really awesome
for me
why did you like the Leppa said well
what was it what was uh what about it
was your favorite
I felt like we it was a long episode
wasn't a podcast Jean the the it was
like our longest almost three at two or
three hours I know it was over - right
and it felt like no time went by at all
like you it the best episodes in the
world for me is when it just goes by and
the clock is just way later than I
thought it was like the conversation is
like effortless yeah yeah and so how
about this how about we listen to a
snippet from the love episode full
snippet well I answer a question from
love and then we'll come back Ryan and
we'll talk about my favorite episode of
the year and we've got a few other
little things to talk about this year
including some added value for the end
of the year perfect for Christmas time
Ryan and I both have an added value
recommendation and I'm eager to talk to
you about perfect for Christmas uh so it
is Christmas Day right now yes so it are
they like it's perfect for Christmas
time because because people have like
this extra time you're sitting around
the house and or they want to go do
something oh yeah absolutely that they
enjoy this meaningful experience we've
got some good added value coming up yeah
amen
all right well here is a little bit from
what we're gonna answer a full question
and have a conversation this is from our
love episode with Peter Rollins our next
question is from Justin in Cleveland
there was a woman that I was an in
relationship with I brought me events
valium and I loved her very dearly but
she broke up with me so I wanted to know
when is it time to move on and say the
relationship is over and when is it
still a time to continue to pursue that
relationship so it's interesting the
again the language that he's using it to
posit this question so this woman broke
up with him and of course I just want to
I want to put this caveat out there I
mean obviously know as know and if
someone breaks up with you
and that you they don't owe you anything
they don't owe you an explanation they
don't owe you an hour of their time to -
let's try to work this out they don't
owe you
I totally together when someone tells
you no you should respect it yeah
absolutely now that said also Justin
sorry for your loss like this is
obviously huge loss for him so I want to
empathize a little bit with him yeah and
I think that the other language he used
here is when is it time to move on and
he's give up and and I would just say
that now is the time to move forward now
that does that mean moving on or giving
up I don't know Peter I heard you talk
about this once like sometimes when when
you get into an argument with your
significant other and someone says get
out of here they don't actually mean get
out of here sometimes - there's that
there is the literal meaning but then
there's this sort of the there is a
figurative meaning behind get out of
here it also means stay and let's work
this out no way yeah no yeah and
language is a complicated thing and
Justin I you know I've been in a similar
place and you know so many of us hopping
and it is deeply devastating one of the
things I would say is what did he injure
that happens when you break up with
someone is that they're very breaking up
changes the dynamic it's just such an
extent that you start to fantasize that
the other person could fix everything so
what happens is often when a breakup
happens the person isn't just somebody
really nice that you could have had a
good life with the person starts to
become in your unconscious fantasies the
one that would fix you entirely the one
yeah that's the key to our friend Colin
right has a great book called some
thoughts about relationships and he has
these different like chapters in there
and one of them is about not looking for
the one like the the whole Jerry Maguire
thing you complete me is like yeah in
fact I think in the book he's he's you
want to look for the person that in
completes you yes that you in complete
me is is the more realistic yeah because
really when you say you complete me it's
you complete me for right now what but
also it presupposes that you
are not a whole person by yourself and
that you need someone else in order to
fill in this sort of this inadequacy
that you currently contain very
existential so I avoid even the
wholeness words but we already have to
get its out but here's the problem I
would say that psychoanalytically we are
all very susceptible to the notion of
the one you see in philosophy the one is
the absolute or God in LA there's the
tyranny of happiness the the one is fear
more money or looks so we are very prone
to and the reasons are because it's
what's called the drive we have this dry
for something that will complete us we
all have that temptation and so in in
this environment for Justin this woman
come the Teac top spot and it's there's
no easy way out except sometimes it'll
be a bit of a bit of psychotherapy or
whatever but eventually you get to the
point of going maybe it would have been
a good relationship maybe it would have
been a great relationship maybe we would
have had a wonderful life together but
that but it wouldn't have completed you
the what's happened is she's become an
idol she's become a figure that is so
absolute that you will not be able to
enjoy your life what's the alternative
to an idol then yeah yeah kind of in one
sense to break the idol very gradually
you kind of need to break this fantasy
of the one and it's very hard to do to
break but to break this fantasy and it
does mean for Justin he may as as I say
go
she's amazing that would have been
fantastic but it's also going but you
know what
I have other possibilities other life
opportunities other things will open up
but it can take years to to get to that
point you know it's really it's really
really tough and because you're not
consciously making the person the one
you're unconsciously doing it so no
matter how much you consciously try it
and not do it you're fighting your
unconscious and your unconscious is much
stronger than your conscience
now what about this language of giving
up I mean the the thing I remember a
particular relationship I was in it was
with the woman who threw scissors at me
and we won't go into detail but there
was a time where we got into like I'm
not prone to fight and I'm also I take
things very literally when you know
she's like you get the F out of here and
I'm like okay I'm walking - like where
are you going and I'm like you just told
me to leave like I was having yeah I'm
leaving is before the the scissors
incident ended everything but but yeah
it's like get out of here and I'm like
okay like I respect what you're saying
goodbye and and then it's like well
where the hell are you going well it's
funny cuz like what she and I I I know
who you're talking about in their
personality and you know she might have
thrown that out there get out of here
but really she wanted you to fight for
her right which I don't know if that's
healthy or not but there are some women
who like to be chaste there yeah and I
don't really I think man especially yeah
because we can often be you know
achiever and for me like significance is
a big drive for doing what I do right
like and so I have to I have to keep
that in mind like the question you asked
earlier like Who am I doing this for
right and and like Who am I trying to I
were to repository and and then why and
so so maybe we could talk a little bit
about that maybe we could talk about
these sort of the language behind the
language yeah I mean and this this is
the core of language itself whenever in
America there's a philosopher she's act
about this and I've experienced it
myself in America you guys say how are
you doing I think it's whenever you go
into a shop people say are you having a
good day or whatever and at first it's
very weird because you're like oh well
thanks very much for asking well I just
had an argument with my mom and I was
out my sisters being like yeah you was
in hospital and you know and then you
realize no they're not out they're not
asking you that right I'm being an idiot
they're not asking you how is your day
going they are showing that they're
there they're making a connection so you
guys from American knew that but I don't
back in Ireland we always refuse food
twice before the third time so if I come
right into your house and you say would
you like some food I'll always go no and
then first time in America I did this I
said no no I couldn't eat a thing and
the person said ok and I'm like hi rude
so you could like you know you could
like if y'all some food to go no no I
really couldn't
oh no seriously have a sandwich no no I
could like I honestly couldn't eat a
thing no no please have a sandwich he
hasnt fama shhhhht
right that's the thing so again you
there's an interesting that in every
society there are the rules and the
matter rules and when you go into a new
society you just knew the rules you
don't know the matter rules this is one
way of always knowing if someone doesn't
fit so if you go to a high-class dinner
and the person does everything right
well you knew that they don't fit
because to be in a high-class dinner is
to know when to obey the rules and when
to disobey the rules if someone Abbes
all the rules it's obvious that they're
trying too hard so you know I actually
have no I've got lots of examples of
that but so even whenever I say to you I
want you to leave I'm really might be
saying I want you to fight to stay if
you're in a relationship and and it's
very difficult to write the meta rules
the matter rules are the shared set of
rules that a culture or a community kind
of knew and the someone outside the
community is completely oblivious to
just the two people it could be just
that relation you might have your own
meta rules you have your own materials
and very you know people who are very
kind of psychotic or have psychosis of
sorts
they're very literal so whenever they go
to a party they find the party
completely bizarre because everybody is
lying you know saying it saying how are
you doing but they're not asking how
you're doing they're you know they're
all of these they knew the rules but
they don't know the matter rules and so
parties are this weird space where
everybody's lying but of course
everybody's not lying and if people are
just knew that matter rules yeah
so that it's an interesting thing about
language yeah oh by the way also in
direct communication the most direct way
to speak is indirectly ie you know if I
say to you I want you to leave well I
want you to stay but how do I find out I
only find out if I say I want you to
stay then you can stay even if you do
won't say right but if I say I want you
to leave and you go no I really want to
stay and work the site then I get to the
truth that's the difference being a
parable and a command right if I'm in
the army and I say it's cold in here
close the door right close the door you
have to obey me I'm giving you a command
you have to do it but if I go hoarse
chilly and here if you're a nice person
you'll close the door if you're not you
won't right and so a parable speaks to
the heart a command speaks to the you
know the mind and a lot of language has
to be parable I get housed in order to
find out something you you can't speak
directly yeah yeah I think that that in
in Justin's case here I mean you have to
take literally if she's like hey we're
done
but then also they're not knowing how
long you've been in this relationship
there probably is some meta language
here that you have to know whether or
not you are moving on is this worth one
more one more shot is it worth one more
discussion and you have to respect if
she says well no I don't want to have
any more discussions I'm going to block
your phone number or whatever or we just
need some time apart you can you can
still approach that literally in a way
and say hey look I realize what you're
saying to me would it be possible to sit
down would you be willing to those five
words that change everything for me
would you be willing to sit down with me
for half an hour so we can talk about
this rationally and afterward if you
want to walk away totally understand
that there's a mess I mean it's
difficult because we all know there's a
messiness to relationships and so
there's a way if someone says for
example no we've broken up there's a
messiness there but there's a way to
respectfully there for example you don't
stalk up stalking is where you basically
then don't take no for an answer right
but there's another thing which is where
you send a letter and in the letter you
say listen this is how I feel this is
where we're at and that's a bit messy
because the person said like maybe I
don't want to ever talk to you again and
you've disobeyed her because you've sent
them a letter that's not stalking
stalking is where you are refusing the
writing a letter isn't isn't a bad thing
no writing a hundred letters under tax
month you know the person's expectation
and they have really poor expectations
where where for me like there's a
relationship I'm talking about where she
was like get the hell out of here I'm
like okay like that was honestly the
best thing to do in retrospect as well
because like she literally wanted to
stay in fight and like it was an
unproductive it wasn't like stay and
fight for me it would stay and fight
with me structure that's very painful
for people you have it where they can
only mint tea in their desire through
conflict through jealousy through
fighting and that can be very taxing on
a relationship unless the two people
like it and then it kind of can work
okay but sometimes somebody they have to
each generate conflict not because they
like the conflict but because the
conflict is what allies than too minty
in their desire but if you're not that
type of person I'm not that type of
person
yeah and that type of relationship is
just gonna drian you worse whereas if
actually two people I knew I know a
couple and they're very fiery and
they're always argue you know but it's
like a they both love us and I look out
and go hard my goodness that would be
exhausting to me I couldn't do it but
they um they're in it for the fight
they're in it for the fight and they
love us and they're like honestly first
time I met them I was like oh this is a
bit this is a bit happy they're having
this conflict dinner table and then as I
hung out with them as I owner they love
each other so much and they get so much
out of this tension that's how they
define passion and a way for them
whereas for someone else for me that
would wreck a relationship and so you
have to figure out those own the the
rules and the metal rules of a
relationship in order for it to work so
with Justin if he has already put in
this this healthy pursuit you know and
she's not giving you anything back you
gotta let it go but the other thing too
I want to tell Justin is you know really
look at because she may or may not have
done this for him I mean he didn't say
but I'm gonna assume she gave him a
little bit of feedback like no I don't
want to be with you because of X Y & Z
either directly or indirectly right and
Justin can look in the mirror and and
this is what I think he should do he
should look in the mirror and say
you know what she's right
you know XY and Z I really do need to I
do need to focus on and that's an area
that I've always had a you know problem
with and then you know start start
having those you know short term actions
aligned with those long term values and
beliefs that's the things like it like
you know generally one person's problem
is another person's desire so for
example you if for argument's sake
somebody might say you know you're too
you you're too passionate or whatever
you just fly off the handle too quickly
but then there's some people right there
go no I want that so you know the the
bit and the big thing for me for Justin
is is I guess he has let it go us and
physically as an you know but I'm
guessing he's more talking emotionally
how do I let go in my mind and I think
what you're saying is very important
which is I think to let yourself feel
everything to let yourself feel like
don't don't run away into other pursuits
into work or in the things there's the
beautiful free is in creative yards
which says gone but not forgotten
which means someone's died but that you
who remember them but in in
psychoanalysis there's a notion of the
forgotten but not gone which is where
you try to forget something but it
ruined means within you not a TRG apart
where where you pretend it's not there
you keep eating you know the soup even
though there's a turd in it you're like
this kind of tastes like [ __ ] but you
just keep eating it over and over and
over and you try to like pretend it's
not there but it's it's going to be
there until you deal with it so going
with this you know the shit's do example
um what I was getting at is that would
Justin he can maybe look in his stew and
be like you know what she's right
there's a piece of [ __ ] in this stew huh
or maybe he looks at it looks in the
sunís like no this is actually really
good stew and I really really love this
stew and even though she feels that way
like don't I guess what I'm really
trying to give advice a Justin here is
like maybe there is something you have
to change maybe but but ultimately if he
can look in the mirror and be like no I
really love Who I am and you know I
don't know why she broke up with me and
whatever reasons it was and I really
don't agree with her but I really do
love Who I am
well then Justin you've got to find
someone who loves you for who you are
and she didn't love you for who you were
that's okay
if you can't do that that's the last
attraction is sometimes we can't do what
can't move on like and that's very
important for all this is like it's not
because there's consciously you know
what you cut conscious advice and then
there's the what the unconscious wants
and that's why I'm always actually very
skeptical of advice because advice
always talks to consciousness when we
have to shift the unconscious and so
hiders if f justin for example is you
know he wants to move on he wants to
forget but he can't what does he do and
that's where that's where I think this
trying to just feel everything and maybe
get a therapy where you're you talk
through everything and you bring it all
to the surface and that just that
process can be enough to Bri act out
psychic link it might help you might be
the thing that helps you move on by
bringing to the surface and and yes your
your letting it go in in one sense but
it will follow you for a while and even
as you move forward killer cop and burn
all her stuff make it burn all the
photographs so the other option is to
try to feel your thoughts and mourn and
move on or to project your thoughts
alright that was love with Peter Rollins
were back and the episode that really
stood out to me was another one of those
conversations we had with Canyon City
Paul Johnson from Canyon City it was
episode 1 2 3 so of course that's why
it's my favorite it's the most OCD
episode yeah and no we had this
conversation with with Paul from Canyon
City about hobbies but it turned into
something so much more like when you
turn your passion or your hobby into a
job and it becomes the primary money be
count becomes the primary driver of
doing that thing how it often kills the
passion in the thing that you once loved
and so he's a musician and you know
moved to the big music city of Nashville
and then basically started writing some
jingles
was like oh is this is this what I love
yeah cuz it doesn't feel like loved what
a way to kill your passion or love for
something is force yourself to make
money from it I think or make money the
primary driver like that is yeah it was
a great conversation specifically with
why putting a dollar amount on what you
should make from what you love or what
you're passionate about is a perfect
recipe for killing that passion it
absolutely is and he has he has backed
away from that as you'll hear in this
snippet from from the episode and the
way we connected with him was really
interesting because I just loved his
2017 album called satellite mm-hmm I
mean it was my favorite album of 2017
you know at the end of each year in fact
you can go through the minimalists
column slash sound and check out my
end-of-the-year music list for the past
I don't know seven eight years something
like that
but 2017 my favorite album of 2017 was
Canyon City it's beautiful album for
sure and I just tweeted him like hey man
would you like to open up for us on the
less is now tour back at 2017 and he
said I already have tickets to your
Nashville show those of woman and then
we brought him out this year for the
simply southern tour in 2018 he opened
up all those he did a cover version of
every little thing Peter Doran song love
Peter Doran and what he's done and then
Paul to sort of did an Americanized
version of it it was beautiful was
totally different but but equally
beautiful and what I learned is that you
have to walk away from making money the
primary driver but also you can't
pretend that it's not part of the recipe
and I think that's what Paul and Kenya
City are doing well he's got his third
album that's coming out I think at the
top of 2019 I cannot wait yeah it'd be
great and if he if he does indeed put it
out and he's back out here in Los
Angeles we'll be happy to have him back
on but until then how about we listen to
a snippet from that hobby's episode our
first lightning round question is from
Lucy Lucy writes in
is it still a hobby if you make money
from it hmm so I think that really
echoes what you were talking about
earlier Paul you don't have to have a
pithy answer right away we can monitor a
little bit and we'll get there
eventually my I borrowed the short short
pithy answer but this minute will Maxim
hear from Drake and then I added to it
if the outcome is income it's not a
hobby and I really I really think that
quite often we get so caught up in money
so I have this little essay here from
Derek Siver's he is a and you're gonna
love this book it's so he's one of my
favorite writers it's called the mindset
of marketing your music which I don't
love the title and I'm gonna have to
talk to him about the the title of it
it's a new Derek severs we've been
emailing back and forth but he he he's
super talented as a writer he's a great
book called anything you want and but he
has this book that's sort of online I
don't know if he's gonna he put it out a
while ago he's rewriting the whole thing
but this chapter is about money and so
he is he's really short pithy chapters
that I almost like Zinn like and in
their in their brevity
it's called shed your money taboos and
by the way I think this book is more
like a it says it's it's for marketing
your music but I think it's the mindset
of marketing for creative people really
cuz it's it goes way beyond the music
hitting yourself yeah yeah especially if
you're a creative person or you're
trying to create so is that your new
title for it yeah I gotta find something
good cuz he has the best title can you
legally do that just change someone
else's title yeah I've done it already I
changed your title to CEO oh nice if I
like at that sea level congratulations
so it turns out this is happiness I just
walked out right coming back alright so
this is called shed your money taboos
everyone has weird mental associations
with money they think the only way to
make money is to take it away from
others they think that charging for your
art means it was insincere and only for
profit but after being around the music
business for 20 years and knowing
thousands of musicians I've learned this
the unhappiest musicians
I've met are the ones who avoided the
subject of money and now are desperately
broke or need a draining day job
it may sound cool to say money doesn't
matter to say don't worry about it in
the negotiation moment but it leads to a
really hard life then ultimately your
music suffers because you can't give it
the time it needs and you haven't found
an audience that values it the happiest
musicians I know are the ones who
developed a valuable aspect of their
skill and confidently charge a high
price there's a deep satisfaction when
you know how valuable you are and the
world agrees then it reinforces itself
as you can focus on being the best
artist you can be since you've found an
audience that rewards you well for it so
never underestimate the importance of
making money
let go of any taboos you have about it
money is nothing more than a neutral
exchange of value if people give you
money it's proof that you're giving them
something valuable in return so by
focusing on making money with your music
you're making sure it's valuable to
others not only to you I think it's so
important because here's the thing that
my little pithy answer was like if the
outcome is income then it's not a hobby
but that's that's okay here's the thing
I don't want the primary driver of what
I do what I create to be money but I
think it's a part of the process is what
their accessories is saying here like
because otherwise you are if it's if
it's just part of the process but it's
not leading then you're being honest
about you need to earn a living from
that thing and that's okay but if it
becomes the primary driver then we start
to sacrifice you were you were hinting
at that earlier like I had to get rid of
this recording contract because the
primary driver for that record label or
whomever was we got to make this
marketable it has to be it has to we
have to aggregate as many eyeballs as
possible on this thing so that it sells
enough units to make us the most amount
of money possible yeah dude I see you
were Derek Siver's si and I raised you a
Seth Godin I would say go for it
this came out earlier today so I didn't
even think about reading this until you
read that one it the title of this is
I'm not selling anything
so good this jokes gonna be so funny
Josh you know Ella says that to shut up
the title of this is I'm not selling
anything of course you are you're
selling connection or forward motion
you're selling a new way of thinking a
better place to work a chance to make a
difference or perhaps you're selling
possibility generosity or sheer hard
work it might be that the selling you're
doing costs time and effort not money
but if you're trying to make change
happen then you're selling something if
you're not trying to make things better
why are you here hmm so sure you're
selling something perhaps it would be
more accurate to say I'm not selling
something to aggressively invading your
space stealing your attention and
pushing you to do something that doesn't
match your goals that's probably true at
least I hope it is I think that's the
thing with like so we're we've gone on
tour we really hope people show up
you're out on tour right now Paul and
you want people to show up you're
selling yourself you're selling this
performance you're selling your music
you hope people listen to it but you're
also asking for more than just money
quite often we're asking for the most
precious resource someone's attention
yeah absolutely
so I'm an attention and dude I gotta say
man if I'm going out of my way to get
someone's attention then I'm going to
make the most of that time yeah I'm
gonna otherwise you're wasting their
time absolutely what's your pithy answer
Ryan my Pitts the answer is forcing
yourself to make money from a hobby is a
great way to kill your love for that
hobby and going back to what I was
trying to get out of you earlier about
there was this point in your career man
where you were forcing yourself to make
money because you wanted to get out of
that that nine-to-five job which there's
nothing wrong with wanting to to do
something different but when we force
ourselves to make money we start to
compromise a lot of things that that we
normally wouldn't compromise it yes and
in my case the irony was that the thing
that people connect was was is the thing
that I was compromising to make it a
career and so and when I basically
ledges I
define success at that forum like it's
okay I may have to do some things that I
don't want to do to you know have a roof
over my head but I don't want to lose
the thing that I love anymore and so
it's okay if I have to do those things
but to protect that my new definition of
success in music is going to be working
at Home Depot so that I have my nights
free you know to make music and then
that love that took all the pressure off
to make commercially viable stuff and
then now I think it's the authenticity
the honesty that people end up
connecting with and I ended up writing
differently and just sort of took that
that demon off my shoulder you know when
I was when I was in the room and and it
became my job after that so I mean I
still although it's what it's how I make
money now music is still my hobby too
it's what I do
you know for like a lot of people say
well how do you you know how do you
write a record a year just I'm like it's
literally what I do for fun like I you
know I'll go home and I'll it's cheaper
than therapy a lot of times and you know
I it's just it's just one of the ways
that I most enjoy myself it's so true
man it's funny because I think about
what what you and I do Josh and I'm
still having fun and people I know they
look at us and they're like man the
minimalists are so huge now and in in
their fame and whatever people tell us
but dude I still fully expect one day
we're gonna wake up and the rug is just
gonna be like swept out from underneath
that same fear or other people gonna be
like oh like you know what you know the
wrong door right exactly exactly like oh
no we did not mean to buy that album
went to the wrong address are all this
done we're gonna get like you know a
hundred thousand books returned to us
system but ultimately though you know
going to the thing that Josh and I
talked about where you know Josh and I
truly feel like over the last eight
years like you know one of the super
powers we've been able to develop is is
letting go and and I am totally willing
to let go of making money this way just
like you are willing of letting go of
making money that way but it's something
that you always want to do and that's
how I feel about it like this is
something I'm always going to
incorporate in my life it's something
I'm always gonna be passionate and
excited about and I can make money off
of it great but but tomorrow I might not
but as long as I can go find for me it's
being a barista my definition of success
is like you know one day
Josh we actually might be able to be
baristas I mean if all this falls apart
have that coffee shot I know that's like
our plant that's like our plan D I don't
know Weaver would let us work we own a
coffee shop not allowed to touch
anything
they're certain pressure when you own a
coffee shop when like people come over
and like it let me make you a cup of
coffee the explanations are super hot
well well the thing is you come to my
house and I make you a cup of coffee
you're gonna have an awesome cup of
coffee okay that's so but the problem is
a lot of people like because they know
we own a coffee shop they'll send us
like bags of beans and the intentions
are always great but it'd be like if I
wrote a song for you to say thanks for
writing songs Paul and it's like you
would appreciate the the sentiment but
it would be so bad you're nothing like
four chords man like really Wow well
you're not gonna put that song and and
so yeah I mean even like okay like
thanks like but you'd have to like sort
of soldier through the the experiences
of me think he knew that one all right I
gotta stop saying snippets because these
are like full conversations from these
episodes and we're we're answering
questions and and so the next one Ryan
was an episode that you picked and it
was another conversation we had with
with two people you want to talk about
your other favorite episode yeah man so
Rob Bowe and Andrew Morgan came in and
Andrew Morgan he is a director he film
filmmaker he did a film a documentary
called the true cost which is a great
documentary just about what the true
cost is when we purchase things what it
does especially clothes yes and what it
does to the environment and then Rob
Bell I'm sure people have heard us talk
about him before he's a kind of an ex
pastor it was interesting we just went
to see an event with him and Peter
Rollins a couple nights ago yeah and it
was it was so weird because you can tell
he's still a preacher of sorts yeah but
he does it such a good when he said he
reclaimed the art form of the
which is yeah you could tell that yeah
the other night yeah so he so like he's
still a preacher of sorts but what I
really like about Rob Bell is he doesn't
like fish of religion down your throat
he doesn't you know he doesn't get like
super Jesus he like he's able to
communicate a message of spirituality
and of of religion you know of sorts but
he doesn't in a way that isn't
off-putting and that's specifically what
I really liked about this episode we did
because we did talk about religion but
again another episode that was very
therapeutic for me I was gonna say this
is another another Ryan Nicodemus
therapy said yeah it was great man cuz
like being raised as in the watchtower
and tract society AKA jehovah's
witnesses it was i was apathetic because
you know the dogmatix i had were very
very any anytime were raised with a
certain set of dogmatix it's it's very
difficult to just let those go and I
feel like that conversation that we had
with Rob and with Andrew it really
helped me to you know maybe not let go
of them but but be at peace with with
you know kind of my past and being
raised and in that in that religion yeah
sort of loosening your grip on the the
[Music]
ideology that had been so heavily
ingrained in your life yeah so we called
this episode religion let's listen to
that conversation right now our first
question is from Claudia in Italy
what is the minimalist take on religion
like is it a simple religion that you
follow or yeah that that is really my
question like what is your take on
religion do you think pointless or does
it really align with the values that you
have that would be my question so thank
you Ryan what is a minimalist take on
religion I think it's hard for you and I
to agree on religion or spirituality I
mean that question is almost like asking
you know what is the Christian take on
religion or what is the Muslim
on what is a human take on gravity oh
yeah man yeah what's your opinion on
gravity uh I have a theory no man I am
here there are two things we don't talk
about on this show and that's religion
and politics because Josh and I differ
so much in it
but uh I was I was telling Rob before
the show here how this is like I've
really kind of like using this show as
an excuse to kind of talk a little bit
about religion because you know you and
I Josh we do have two completely
different beliefs but what what I really
think that people can take away from our
beliefs is that even though we do have
different beliefs we solve a very
awesome friendship we have a very
awesome business we are able to you know
talk to and bring a crowd of people who
are Christians Jewish atheist Muslim
like whatever it is it's it's a very
diverse crowd and and I think I think
maybe we could talk about it a little
bit I like what you said earlier Rob
when I brought up religion you said no
no no let's not talk about religion you
said what what did you say let's talk
about well what is the nature of reality
what kind of world are we living in so
you can say that you have very different
beliefs but if I watch you closely over
the past couple of years you all
actually have very very similar beliefs
hmm that many people when they say
beliefs what they're talking about is
intellectual furniture how is your
cognitive hardware arranged which is
just intellectual assent what do you in
your rational capacities agree with or
disagree with yeah but there's actually
the place that you live from there's
actually a much deeper seat of the beam
the Greeks prefer to thus plankton which
is like the the bowels the seed of the
guts which is the place from which you
actually live and that the two of you
actually if you if you spent hundreds
and hundreds of days on the road
together and you've built a business and
you spend hours together there's great
mutual love and trust and respect
between you then how you actually live
as your beliefs are actually closely
aligned yeah
thing I think certainly our values are
aligned I think we're maybe using the
terms differently whether it's beliefs
or values Ryan and I have similar values
I think that's why it works okay maybe
we don't even use the word beliefs here
we have different personalities for sure
you know lions the extreme extrovert I'm
an introvert and you know we have
different sort of political believes we
voted for two different people in the
last election there were more than two
people to vote for but it's often the
case that when people are talking about
beliefs oftentimes underneath whatever
those surface categories and labels are
there is great agreement and bonds and
convictions that are very very similar
yeah so that's why I always I always
want to poke that bubble with people
with like wait wait wait what are you
talking about because underneath the
surface lots of people that would appear
to be different are actually much close
or closely aligned so the surface can be
manufactured by absolutely geography or
by the the community that you were you
raised in edia religion yeah authority
figures etc social media well no I was
just gonna say like when I read this
question I was thinking about I was
thinking about like how I grew up
viewing religion so I was raised you up
as witness as I talked about with you on
my yeah my last podcast on your podcast
that I first and your first podcast and
what's to me like when I think about how
I was raised
as a Jehovah's Witness here here's the
narrative it is you Ryan Nicodemus
you're imperfect Jesus died for your
sins um in order for you to be saved you
have to you have to follow these rules
you have to get baptized in Jesus's name
so then that way he can forgive you for
your sins and that's that is um that's
the main narrative there there was
nothing in that I was taught growing up
with things like the environment right
for things like finances I mean there
was a time when Jehovah's Witnesses they
were
it was in the early 80s like late
seventies they were predicting the end
of the world and these these sheep were
and I'm not using that pejoratively I'm
to were you know they're they are doing
what they feel is right they're going
out and they they literally just got
these huge loans and like just
accumulated all this debt because they
were like oh the end of the world is
coming
I mean fact the people within your tribe
growing up I mean absolutely this is
this is I mean I think this is
tantamount to child abuse to a certain
extent you were told you don't worry
about college because you're never going
on 18 years old when I was 25 years I
think how that sets a child yeah I went
to my boss at 25 and I was like hey our
company pays for schooling I want to go
to college like can you help me out and
she was like she looked at me like no
one ever sat down with you and taught
you how to like approach a college I'm
like no I have no idea what to do and
it's in it is because of that but but
where I'm going with this is you know
the thing that really frustrates me
about that upbringing is that let me
unpack this this statement I got a
prophecy cuz it's gonna sound really bad
but this this this thing of pray to God
and rely on God for everything that to
me used to be my saving grace like to me
that was like that that that thought of
God will take care of it I don't need to
worry about it I love God God loves me
and I know because of that that I could
pretty much judge anyone I want to judge
I can project any you know anger that I
have towards these people that I'm
judging and God's got my back the other
thing too is that it absolved me from
any responsibility for things like the
environment meaning my my thought was I
don't worry about the environment cuz
Jesus he's gonna come back he's gonna
wave his magic hands and he's gonna make
everything better so why would I care
about the environment and to me
well there's literally got a written
down here uh revelation 11:18 where it
talks about God ruining destroying the
people who are ruining the earth
and and that in that description as an
only reason I know that Scripture is
because of being a drove as witness
because they do they do such a good job
of using the Bible but I guess there are
things like that that stand out to me
that really started to make me question
my where I was putting all of my beliefs
and I and I guess where I stand on I
would be interested to see what you
think about this where I stand now or I
guess where I wear it kind of it's not
even where I stand it's where I it's
where I like I'm kind of settled right
now but I'm totally open to changing
this but I feel like there are times in
my life this morning I'm driving to work
and I'm like I'm praying like I really
want this to be an awesome podcast like
help me help me to please make this an
awesome podcast if you're up there and
you're listening help me to make this an
awesome podcast there are other times in
my life where I feel like I need to take
an atheist point of view because I feel
like putting everything on God and not
trying to figure out something myself
first it's kind of lazy it's kind of
mature on childish yes so it done oh
there are so many times in life where I
get to a point where yeah I try and
can't do it and then and then yeah I've
got to look somewhere else um it's it's
I'm not trying to say that I am an
atheist in fact I am I would say I'm a
believer and it's because of your book
Love Wins that even made it possible for
me to have this belief because this is
such a crazy I mean me saying this out
loud it sounds really radical and weird
and I don't know if there's anyone else
out there who like agrees with me on
this but it doesn't matter because this
is it does come from a very loving spot
it does come from me being very genuine
yeah yeah and yeah I'm happy to share it
even though it sounds nuts am I crazy
what do you think No thank you first off
I think you speak for millions of people
thank you I'm so sorry you had that it's
as if the point is that we would wake up
and grow up we would grow up in our
awareness of who we are what we're doing
here that we would wake up and see our
infant
connections with ourselves with each
other with the earth with the entire
cosmos and what you were describing is a
a giant religious machine that was
impotent when it comes to the
transformation of the human heart mmm
it gave you rules customs rituals fears
interpretations of revelation 11 yeah
but what it seemed to fall completely
short in is actually helping transform
your heart mmm help you be more Ryan
yeah it's the only interesting thing
camellias the UM the most true full Ryan
is what the world needs the most of so
even going back to when people start
twitching about religion I immediately
say what in your life has no other
purpose than to help grow you up wake
you up and transform your heart mmm
because I don't think the business world
is that I don't think academics I don't
know if entertainment has that mmm and
historically what happened is lots of
people tossed out primitive barbaric
awful end of the world sort of religion
which they should have but the processes
they threw out an entire dimension of
life which historically its point was to
help transform you helped shape you and
grow you there's a scene in the film in
The Heretic with
with Pete Holmes and he's talking about
like it's it's pretty funny money
metaphor and I'll all butcher oh but
he's basically talking about getting rid
of the ottoman that you didn't want in
your house that's not the interesting
thing the interesting thing is is sort
of sitting there with that empty space
and figuring out what you're going to
fill it with and I think what you're
talking about is is jettison the the the
not useful or damaging side of what
we've been given but then what do we do
then what do we fill it with that we
just have this void whether you call
that a spiritual void or or just a life
void in general who's teaching us how to
live a meaningful life now right right
and you think about we're at an
emergency level with the environment
yeah so we need millions and millions
and millions of people to wake up and
grow an awareness to our endless
connections with the soil and that will
require an opening at a deep spiritual
level it may have economic dimensions
it'll have like hey there is no planet B
I mean there's like a fear terror you
can show all the movies you want but at
some deep level that is a spiritual
question that lurks underneath
everything and to deny that dimension of
it you'll never actually get at the
thing you have to tap into a deep sense
of stewardship and responsibility that
comes and those are all spiritual
matters and in the modern world a lot of
times like TED Talks don't know what to
do is spirit because it can't be proven
on a spreadsheet it can't be tested in a
lab but spirit that which is
inaccessible through the five senses and
yet is more real than that which you can
hold in your hand is the giant for many
people it's been the elephant in the
room well we can't talk about spiritual
things well you're going to have to at
some point eventually but that's like
also the great opportunity that we're
living in that's what's so inspiring
about being alive right now it's like we
spent the last decade or two decades
basically deconstructing a lot of our
institutional systems or institutional
beliefs so that's not just religion
that's you know you think about our
belief in any kind of institution it's
just declined declined to Kleck it's
also we're living in a world that was
built half a century ago in a lot of
ways like we're still playing out the
end of a story that was started and we
know we need to transition to a new one
but we don't know how to get there so to
your point I think like there's millions
of people who are in that place with
religion or with anything where you're
like okay that stuff didn't work you
know to your point Ryan like that right
that crazy [ __ ] didn't work at all right
did a lot of damage but but what's left
in that void when there's no no together
thinking when there's no ability to look
beyond as Rob says the five senses and
figure out like what is happening like
never wake up and you're just kind of
like really like does this mean anything
or doesn't mean nothing yeah if it's
possible that it means something
then maybe we need to start figuring out
what it looks like to tell a story that
leads us where we want to go not just
into these dead ends you know and that
like what you're describing Josh it's
like we are in that transition we are
literally in a turning point in human
history and you can feel it absolutely
absolutely and think about your path you
grew up in this narrow Bonkerz do you
use a technical theological term I'm not
oscar's this is not a fenced any java's
witnesses nothing out there it's nothing
but love but you describe something that
had some damaging effects sure but then
you turned around and you've given these
big vibrant energies of yours I mean I
went to that when I went to that your
event in LA it was like a big living
room was all of these people coming
together in the name of human community
and solidarity to ask questions and talk
about meaningful lives yeah so so you
have in many ways it's like you're
writing it wrong well you know it's
funny man is I read your OVAs witness
you know my conversion rate was robbing
you you went door to door or door every
weekend knocking on doors isn't in this
fascinating and now you're going venue
to venue except we're not trying to
convert anyone right all right I think
we're trying to share a recipe and I
think that's what's different now yes
where it's not like you must live the
same way I live it's hey here's a
template that's worked for me a recipe
has worked for me I don't hope you use
the same recipe in fact I think it's
gonna be difficult for you to but maybe
there's a few ingredients in that recipe
you can tweeze out you can apply to your
own life yeah it's in you know you can
add your own ingredients for taste and
then and you have your own recipe for a
more meaningful life because my life
life looks differ from his from yours
from yours and and the the reason that I
think it resonates is one of the things
that you guys were talking about with
the film is it's quite often about
asking questions more so than it is
giving answers right you said Ryan grew
up with essentially an instruction
manual on how he's supposed to live and
instead of us giving people and we're
not prescriptive in that way it's it's
saying hey what are the questions how my
life be better with less is is much more
meaningful than here are the 30 items
you're supposed to own and your
collection of whatever to be happy way
it's it's the it's the why to behind
what a living a meaningful life I think
that's what we do a really good job of
but going back to my conversion rate so
let me say it another way I didn't save
one one life when I was one of Joe's
witnesses now my conversion rate is
still zero but I can't tell you how many
people have come up to me a line they're
like dude you don't know me I feel like
you're my best friend
and you saved my life and if it was just
one person who told me that it would
make it all worth it but that I mean
literally that is the reason why I
continue to do it and I'll tell you man
I have my two biggest fears of doing
this my two biggest fears the first one
is is that people start to think that
Josh and I are like Jesus Christ or
something like that really freaks me out
the second fear is is that being raised
as one of Jove as witnesses I was told
that if you're not a jobless witness
while you're being influenced by Satan
the devil so like I a lot I have to look
in the mirror and be like dude are you
the devil like are you being influenced
by Satan like I really have to face that
and I'll tell you because of the events
because of what you witnessed that
there's no way I can be doing wrong and
if I am then then then I guess I
disagree with whoever thinks this is
what I'm doing is wrong you know yeah
absolutely
no absolutely for sure so for me I guess
when it comes to minimalist religion I
guess there isn't there isn't one
religion that Josh or I will ever say
hey this is the one religion that that
you should that you should have or these
are the beliefs that you should have I
think for me it's about what what is it
that my my heart and my mind
tell me are good morals like what is it
that makes me feel guilty
because I hate feeling guilty so
whatever makes me feel guilty I don't do
that
and when ever makes me feel like I am
being a genuine person and adding a lot
of value to other people's lives then I
do that so for anyone out there who's
you know confused on religion I would
say start there and then maybe start to
pick and choose what tribes you want to
maybe be involved with if there's a
tribe at all there you want to be
involved
and you I feel like the this making this
film was a bit of a search for you or
maybe the beginning and then the process
of a search during the QA the other
night you were talking about how it was
in one way sort of your most personal
film even though it's about Rob but it
was almost like you were searching you
know by proxy right and you had this
proxy of of change of asking different
questions questions that maybe you
weren't used to can you talk a little
bit about that that search for you
because it sounds to me like that's what
Claudia is asking here she's she's also
searching yeah for sure I mean I think
that was that was thing for me when I
met Rob I had I had come from a
background that was very conservative
very evangelical I had grown away from a
lot of that and so I think when I met
Rob I was really interested in the
things he was talking about because it
it was fascinating to me just on like a
personal level you know like it was a it
was a totally different way to approach
some of these ideas and that was super
super super interesting to me and then
also I think I think for me like I I'm
just super super interested and this is
why I really respect the work you guys
are doing I'm very interested in the
ways that the stories that we believe
and the stories that were telling really
are the shaping and defining our world
and I think I had come through a period
I had told some stories before this I
had done some work that was much more
just on the general like journalistic
awareness like there are some
emergencies happening on planet earth
and if we can just get more people to
know about them then we'll inevitably
create a better world and I had sort of
bumped up against the edge of that so
for me it was like I'd sort of put
religion so I kind of put that stuff
behind me I'd sort of leaned fully into
this idea of there are things happening
there is suffering there there are
issues in front of me that I can do
something about and I think what made it
interesting again was this subtle sense
of wait how does the whole thing move
forward and what is holding it back so
both on a very personal standpoint what
does it take for human beings to wake up
like we haven't figured out how to
forgive our enemies we can't seem to get
endless war and violence and out of
circulation and and so maybe there are
tools buried in some of these traditions
that could help us right now so both on
an individual basis maybe there are
tools that can help me make sense of the
life that I find myself living and then
collectively maybe if we're serious
about moving forward maybe if we're
serious about building a more just more
humane future up ahead
then we need to stop just putting
band-aids on we need to start looking at
what are the root causes and certainly
for me living in America I don't think
you can take I don't think you can
understand this country this context
this moment we're living in without
taking seriously the impact that
religion has had and you could argue for
them for the worse for the better
irrelevant to me it has a stranglehold
on our collective moral imagination and
so for me that just became really
interesting if you were if you were to
walk down the street maybe not in LA but
if you were to walk down the street
there or in ask 10 people it was Noah's
Ark a real event it was it a real
historical event 60 percent of the
people will say yes so to me that it's
to your point of how strong of a hold
religion has well and again this isn't
this isn't for or against religion we're
just talking about what it is yeah I
think what Robert saying is you're
asking the wrong question that was the
other thing happened is you know we we
started making this film in 2015 and
then 2016 rolled around and we had an
election mm-hmm and it was like we
watched as all the knobs got turned up
and and it was like religion came to the
surface again yeah again for better or
worse if you if you started noticing and
I was noticing just because I happened
to be making a film so I was watching
the news and a different way I was and
as I listened to the vocabulary as I
listen to the examples we use as I
listen to like our collective
touchstones you know like mm-hmm they
are rooted in these traditions and this
one tradition in particular so I think
get it instantly was like oh this isn't
ancillary this cuts to the heart of this
thing that we're doing my favorite line
in the in the heretic about religion I
think was Pete Holmes he said a bunch of
this help me help me help me get this
line right but it's he said something
along the lines of if you really want to
know like you know if you have the right
religion or not like look at look at
what you use your religion for I know
I'm like paraphrasing this and
butchering it but it was about what does
it make you do what does it make you do
does your religion - is it divisive is
it is it is it oh that's what it was is
it does your religion exclude you or
does it or does it include everyone and
to me like that is Pete Rollins I hear
Owens too late Pete's and they had too
many Pete's um well yeah and yeah but uh
that to me like that is the can you say
that again with an Irish accent every
time I do an Irish accent it comes
across as like Eastern Europe yeah I
don't know why but but but you know
again for Claudia here you know that's
that's the question that I ask myself
like with any religion anyone who's
trying to to - because people come to us
all the time oh you know it's so nice
like they'll come up and give us a nudge
like it's so nice to see two Christians
going out and spread and spread and
Jesus's message and then like you know a
few people later they're like yes and
then they'll come up and they'll say you
know to see two young men like you going
around and spreading the teachings of
Buddha is so encouraging and and and you
know any religion that gets presented to
me that's kind of how I look at it I'm
like is this a it does this religion
exclude or does it include and and for
me that is kind of I guess one of the
main identifying marks of my beliefs I
guess maybe you could have an official
statement for the minimalists is that we
are trans religious and all that we do I
love that and we're we're we're very
religious maybe your your official like
we are trans religious we work to create
a space where people from every
tradition or no tradition feel welcome
to pursue with us the issues of deepest
fullness and vitality so see Sean all
you have to do is I
you get a question about religion so I
have it on like the little sound board
yes you have no problem with these
traditions to the degree to which these
traditions help shape the kinds of
people yeah
yes and I want to be clear that
minimalism is not I don't feel like
minimalism is a substitute for these
things I don't feel like I don't feel
like someone could stop being a
Christian and then you know take up this
philosophy and still feel fulfilled
I think minimalism is a tool well you
know it's sticking with the religious
theme look at all the the major prophets
in any religion like there is one major
thing they all have in common and they
that's all living a simple life yeah
right yeah right so yeah again I don't
think I don't think minimalism is a
supplement but I certainly think it's a
tool like at all
all right so finally Ryan my other
favorite was an episode we did early in
the year after doing a bit of a social
media hiatus so at the end of 2017 we
decided okay let's just delete all of
our Instagram posts let's delete all of
our tweets and let's get off social
media for a month so all of January 2018
we were just all social media we went
dark and we didn't really say anything
to anyone we posted this sort of cryptic
video of us and static and you know and
then it was gone
and you know what we didn't have an
expectation other than we hope to learn
something out of this month and what we
learned is that we were using social
media well in effectively right well I
was I'll push back a little bit and say
we were using it okay yeah but that's
just it we were using it okay we weren't
we weren't being as deliberate as as we
are with most other things in our lives
yeah and I think that's a good point so
we weren't using it deliberately and and
that was evidenced by well sort of yeah
if I would post something to Instagram
then I would repost it to Facebook and
re repost it to Twitter and then maybe
do a pinned thing on Pinterest and still
pin stuff we do use Pinterest yeah if
you all if you all find value in that
but here's here's the key the
question we had to start asking is how
can we use these platforms to add the
most value and then the question then
becomes well what is the best use of
this platform we realized like hey
Twitter is a perfect platform for text
so no photos no links only text we can
communicate with other people and we can
also post sort of words minimalist VAR
minimal Maxim's and we can we can do
that sort of through these creative
constraints and it will breed more
creativity by placing this constrain the
Facebook was like hey people really get
value from the Articles we share on
Facebook let's just share articles on
Facebook and then Instagram was like
what about won't use Instagram for
beautiful photos right and then
Pinterest we do these sort of pin boards
or these these boards that Jessica
creates so some of our our quotes and
sayings and also some beautiful
architecture over there
you know re sharing some beautiful
images in a way that people find value
in using these platforms to the best of
our ability without trying to post
everything in triplicate
yeah and does that provide some
constraints yeah but we're not we're not
on these platforms to have some sort of
ROI right yeah what's your ROI on
Facebook I don't know it's probably it's
close to zero dollars well you know it's
funny man when I think about how we used
social social media before we did that
that month long fast the way I looked at
it was well some people won't use only
Facebook some people use only Twitter
some people use only Instagram so maybe
it made a little bit of sense to to kind
of post everything in triplicates sure
looking at it through that lens right
but ultimately yeah we found a way to
use it better and I think that you know
the shotgun approach it's an approach
it's definitely an approach but yeah I'm
really satisfied with what what kind of
came out of that whole experiment what
an interesting analogy the shotgun
approach because shotguns do work to
kill things but you never see anyone go
to war with a shotgun right because it
lacks precision yeah
and and for us like we wanted to I mean
there are trench guns but but for all
intensive purposes what you're saying
yeah right I yeah yeah yeah you're not
gonna go into the battlefield and charge
with a shotgun right it just it just
makes far less sense because the lack of
precision and so what we want to do was
inject some precision into what our
strategy or usage was for these
platforms because you're right Ryan yes
there are some people who don't use
Twitter but they use Facebook there are
some people who don't use Facebook but
they use Instagram right and well that's
true about anything right that there are
some people who don't X but they do why
I mean if we were if we were doing that
a pro if we were still doing that
approach I mean we would be on Yik yak
and you know all the other social media
yeah tik-tok just yes yes it's all
backwards nap chat goodness that's so
wrong no all right anyway here here's a
conversation about social media that we
recorded earlier in the year all right
Mikey wants to know why return to social
media actually make your life more
meaningful or is it really just a modern
platform to advertise he has advertising
quotes there I believe I did that with
my inflection you did and in the radio
business call that a vocal quote as I'm
talking about inflection Josh has his
hands above his head flexing his biceps
like bicep I just have one so here's I
put the answer and then we will talk
about a little bit a paintbrush can
create a masterpiece a paintbrush can
destroy a masterpiece and I don't
paintbrush however does nothing at all
and so the thing that I would just talk
about here is social media is a tool and
it can be both it could be meaningful it
can also be a platform to advertise now
I'm gonna read something really quick
from Derek Siver's a moment ago I was
talking about his book the mindset of
marketing your music which is reworking
on we'll put a link to it and in the
show notes this is real quick the the
title of this chapter is marketing just
means being
consider it don't confuse the word
marketing with advertising announcing
spamming or giving away branded crap
really marketing just means being
considerate marketing means making it
easy for people to notice you relate to
you remember you and tell their friends
about you marketing means listening for
what people need and creating something
surprisingly special for them marketing
means getting to know people making a
deeper connection and keeping in touch
all of these are just considerate
looking at things from the other
person's point of view and doing what's
best for them a lot of musicians say I
hate marketing so yeah if you thought
marketing meant turning off your
creativity spending lots of money and
being annoying then it's a good thing
you don't like that nobody likes that
just find creative ways to be
considerate that is the best marketing
you know it's funny the pithy answer I
wrote I've been writing my pitty answers
without looking at yours haha
because they usually not usually but a
lot of times they descend up saying kind
of the same thing yeah one influences
the other okay so anything has to be
when you write yours first yeah exactly
so oh that's why you switched him around
I was always wondering why you did that
oh really yeah because it used to be
yeah anyway so here's I put the answer a
silent monk sitting in a temple convert
to no one and it's it's just saying the
same thing that you said man someone who
has like a monk I like I look at a monk
I really look up to monks they got a lot
of knowledge um I've had some meaningful
conversation with monks I love talking
about spirituality I love talking about
beliefs I love talking about dogmatix
although all that stuff although we
don't talk about that on the show cuz
that's that's that's typical I like
having those conversations with like one
or two people privately in private I
don't like having those conversations
what's for you so going back to what
Michelle was talking about earlier like
that's a line you draw probably you're
not talking about spiritually because
you feel like it will take away from the
greater good it takes away from the real
or eyes peeled because the tribe thing
we were talking
Zandar it's divisive and that's not what
I don't want to be divisive right um but
yeah but when I think of a monk and how
much I look up to him one can well look
up to a monk if I think of if every
single monk ever like just went to a
monastery and was silent and never left
the monastery then I never would have
had the opportunity to have a really
cool conversation with a monk yeah
wouldn't serve the greater good right
exactly
so you know I would argue that people
who who have an amazing message or story
that they really want to get out there
or something that is going to add value
to to a lot of people it's going to help
in some way they're kind of doing a
disservice by not saying anything yeah
yeah I think so and so that I think
that's the point why why return because
not returning would do a disservice to
our audience and the people who rely on
us to to whisper amongst the noise right
David Foster Wallace has this great
quote in one of his essays he talks
about a guy going to a Metallica concert
and whistling Mozart yeah and and that's
what we're trying to do sometimes it
feels like on social media it's pretty
loud man but we're just gonna come in
there calmly or a speaks softly and not
everyone's gonna hear us but hopefully
some of you will and I think that's
pretty great and III think that yeah
Mikey we're not advertising we don't do
advertisements we have done in the past
I don't think I'll do this ever again
maybe we will put we've done promoted
posts on Facebook but just to our
audience Facebook is its pay-to-play
right and so if we have I don't have any
people for us half a million people on
Facebook if you want to reach all of
them Facebook isn't like it's go and
post something you can reach all of them
they make you pay to reach all of them
but we wouldn't just put up an ad to say
please target you know young women in
Alberta who want to you know listen to
podcast right but sometimes it's just
like we'll use MailChimp occasionally to
send out newsletters from from our
website you have to pay to do that it's
not free
it's just a platform but we don't we
never advertise and so it isn't an
advertisement and you need to understand
the difference between marketing and
advertising marketing is being
considerate as Derek Seaver says and
that's what we're trying to do the
reason we return is to be considerate
and toward our audience okay now it's
time for our added value portion of the
shows where we each talk about something
that has added value to our lives
recently Ryan it is Christmas time it is
Christmas Day jingle bells jingle bells
jingle all the way here's my added value
I'm just gonna sing Christmas songs
there are no playlists for that I'm just
wondering how many people just like just
just closed out of their podcast app
right now all right well let's maybe
let's stay away from that what has been
adding value life of what what what do
you think would be good for someone to
go watch today man um I always on
Christmas I usually would take like my
grandma loved the movies or something I
love going on the movies on Christmas
cuz I love it too it's like a super slow
day and you've got the time to kill and
I don't know what it is man maybe
because I just grew up doing it but
something I love to do I would recommend
people go see the movie Green Book you
Beck's Mariah and I we went saw that a
couple nights ago and hit me right in
the fields man it was it was a great
movie um the the two main characters in
there reminded me of like caricatures of
us so you've got like one gentleman who
is like extremely OCD and then you've
got another guy who is just you know
completely shoots from the hip and messy
extrovert extroverted yeah it was it was
it was good for that sense too but but
yeah I'd really enjoyed the movie um I
don't want to give too much of it away
it's basically about a pianist who is
touring and it's set back in the 60s and
it's about his experience on the road
and then this other gentleman who would
be the Ryan version so the pianist is
Josh he's the OCD guy yeah and then
there's there's the dude driver who is
the opposite and it's about there
their journeys on the road together yeah
and through the deep south in particular
yeah pre-civil rights south its 1962 I
believe is when it takes place and
Herschel Olli and Viggo Mortenson are
starring in this film and they were like
they perfectly complement each other
like they played the roles perfectly and
I agree with you it's a radically
exaggerated version of our relationship
yeah but like the it's an emotional
journey in a way it's it's a feel-good
movie which I love for Christmas
yeah but it's it's also it takes you on
this journey of sadness and some anger
and frustration in order to get to that
you have to earn the good feeling yeah
that you feel well you know in order to
have the peaks man you got to have the
valleys yes indeed as I've learned over
the last year right and I think the aim
is to have shorter Valley spend less
time in valleys and certainly less time
suffering but that's what you learn in
this movie it's it's one of those movies
that has these quotable lines to that
that are just endearing the the Ryan
character played by Viggo Mortensen he
has these he reminded me so much of you
because you might not always have the
right word to say but it doesn't matter
because the way that you say it has all
of the the feeling and emotion and heart
in it that are you talking about when he
talks about tits berg that also reminded
me of you for yet it's it's a great
movie green book and for me if you're
just sitting at home this Christmas and
you look for something to laugh at well
Trevor Noah's new special was called son
of Patricia and it's on Netflix and I'll
tell you that it opens up with two jokes
that you and I have told probably we've
told them several times on the podcast
at this point there's a I'm not gonna
ruin the jokes but there's a joke about
la traffic that you'll often reference
you know he said I'm not saying he sold
these jokes from us he certainly didn't
know there's a such thing as parallel
thinking and so
you have this good joke about about la
traffic he turned it into an outstanding
joke of course and then I have a joke
about camping and about growing up poor
and he has a very similar joke that he
it's a very good joke that he turned
into an outstanding joke but then from
there he just kills it is funny
throughout Beck's and I watched it
together and we were just cracking up
the entire time you gotta watch it it's
called son of Patricia it's a little
Trevor Noah's new special on Netflix
check it out all right we can move on
the right here right now
it is Christmas Day and so I hope you
enjoy your Christmas if you want to
comment on this episode you can do that
over at youtube.com slash the minimalist
you can find a bunch of other really fun
stuff over there quickie episodes living
room conversations Ryan dancing too oh
he's doing it here
shout out to YouTube and also the
Cabbage Patch is still cool no no it's
the Running Man these days right yeah
yeah that's back in the back right well
what else oh yeah if you want if you
want to get the show notes in your email
box just go to the minimalists comm and
enter your email address at the top and
we will send you the show notes anytime
we publish a new episode also any new
writings from the minimalist we do
simple Sundays over at the minimalists
comm and you can get those two show up
right there in your email inbox Ryan you
got anything else for us yeah man I just
want to encourage people to read more
and get a full get informed get a form
get a form read more and get a form and
then fill it out no man I really like
that we're we're saying this on every
podcast now because it is so important
these days to just make sure that we are
informing ourselves with with with
current events and it's it's too easy to
just look at a meme or a headline and
just take it for granted yeah so get out
there read more get informed and then
also let's see what else we got here I
got some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners check them out
beautiful
hi this is Jessica from Cincinnati Ohio
and I was just calling with a few tips
for gift-giving especially with small
children I have four children ages 8 4 6
and 18 months and this year is our first
year of really doing a minimalistic
Christmas some ideas that my husband and
I have come up with for gift-giving are
one consumable so anything like art or
anything project oriented that they can
use up even giving it to the fine trend
this year works out really well for my
kids as well as using it as a devil and
giving those as gifts for their friends
and their homemade making pictures for
friends another idea that we've done
this year is including their favorite
tree we're usually pretty healthy when
it comes to our meals and the way that
you nourish our bodies but every kid
once a bag of Doritos occasionally and
since we don't give in to those wants
and those needs we do try to find a
healthier option or we even given to
like a snack bag of those and fill their
stockings but those kinds of treats and
so they know it's a special occasion and
at moderation is okay even though it's
junk food we try not to completely
restrict them so they don't go to
college and gain 400 pounds when they
are finally free another our last idea
that we really follow that enjoyed this
year my kids have really gotten into is
creating a service project and really
using donations and selling items like
pictures and painting and then find
things for children is easy at the
Cincinnati Children's Hospital in the
cancer ward this year we chose to buy
silly socks so my kids had decided
collectively to take some of their
Christmas present money and in their
honor buy extra socks for the kids that
eat them so there are some great ideas
just in case you're looking for them
especially for small kids because they
get just as much joy out of giving than
they do receiving have a Merry Christmas
this tip is for people who have a lot of
membership loyalty and gift cards at
stores like shoppers optimum or Canadian
Tire instead of carrying them on your
keys or having a lot of cards in your
wallet which make it really heavy and
clunky you can actually digitize them in
a new app called TD wallet I just spent
a few minutes
digitizing I think around 30 or 35 cards
and it was really easy to do and they
have a search functionality so it'd be
really easy to locate your card when you
need them
hi this is Chris from Lansing Michigan I
really like your idea of getting rid of
things during December and we I wanted
my daughter to partake but of course
it's hard for our children the child to
get rid of something especially with
Christmas coming their minds were
thinking about getting stuff so the way
I framed it was that she's making room
for new things that Santa or her Elf on
the Shelf real life sees what she has
and so they will probably get more if
they see her with less so I hope that
helps parents out there that have kids
that want to join in on the fun of
getting rid of stuff they no longer all
right so that's it for this episode if
you have a question for the minimalist
give us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm if you all leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works we'll see you
next year
alright thanks for listening y'all
minimus